hi can I interest you in some
unconditional love looking for something
to slobber on you can he help me well he
mostly works with the dogs I deal with
the
people you have a weird energy don't
worry I've been neutered I want
him Percy can you up this
lady mind if I touch your wiener what
your dog
oh
yeah um how can I help you um I want to
adopt a dog oh
yeah
um it's a cool cartoon it's anime yeah
animated that's what I
said um excuse me I need your help oh
sorry sorry okay what kind of dog are
you looking to adopt well I wish I could
adopt them all which is the most
up um the most messed
up that's your car it is for
tonight actually um you know what uh
this sucks but I I just remembered I
rode my bike here so I this is what I'll
go I'll go run this well that's
okay I can just throw it in the back you
can right up front with me
oh come on I won't
bite unless you want me
to okay but no
biting iing out whatever I've been with
girls a couple times where's the rest of
my seat belt it's a LP belt just pretend
you're on an airplane I'll be your
flight
attendant why is the flight attendant
flying the the plane because I've killed
the pilot and taken over the plane
you're my
hostage this isn't the way to my house
it's a
[Music]
shortcut just
give me that what are you doing cut our
generation in our phones
huh we're
[Music]
home o what you got down there something
for
me
why you tried kidnapping me I can't
kidnap you you're 19 grow up you put me
in a van and you took my phone if I were
kidnapping you I wouldn't give you all
my personal information first God why
couldn't you have used your rape whistle
why would I have a rape whistle why did
you ack
mace sorry will you get the host
please uh uh it's broken is the water on
you have to turn the the water on are
you with me I just thought maybe
it was already the spigot the spigot
okay
oh stop spring me I'm sorry I
trying to help I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm so sorry I just
didn't know what you were trying to do I
just thought you were hot you think I'm
hot yeah I think you're super hot well
maybe we should go on a date
then I'll go throw another dress on oh
no I I didn't mean now I meant you know
tomorrow like a real date oh
oh yeah that's better okay tomorrow
then thank you for the
ride
bye I like your house a lot it's cozy
bedroom's the best part I'll show you
[Music]
later h
oh we're wearing the same
[Music]
shorts did you grow up
dancing smack it yeah me smack it you
want me to smack
it do you have your consent yeah smack
it
harder hit it
how long have you
[Music]
lived hurt a little heavy on my legs you
want to Swift and I feel like
you can't nobody stop the juice so baby
I do you want to go to the
bedroom we can take it slow yeah thank
you are you okay yeah I want to I want
to yeah just a little ity but let's
go sorry does it look
weird that's fine my backage just
to oh my God what
God this happens sometimes when I get
anxious I know you're really horny I'm
sorry this is for board rash but it
should do the
trick have you seen
[Laughter]
Percy is that funny he's with Natalie
upstairs
[Music]
move how
girl Percy yeah wait your name's Percy
yeah
Percy sorry continue
Percy doesn't anyone
anymore Percy
Percy open this door
Percy Percy open this door this is your
last
[Music]
chance did you him oh my
god did you him no no please
nothing happened the room is spinning
you're drunk already no no he took took
something I don't know I think it was a
pill he Percy did you take something
Percy did you take a
pill stick your fingers down your throat
make yourself throw up just deeper
[Applause]
deeper no let me do
it
do you feel
better not even at
all I didn't know you couldn't drink on
ibuprofen that's what you
took found who told the joke okay who
told the joke your parents are
here you think our son would have a
party without our consent that's it come
on you don't belong here I don't belong
here I lived here my whole life
you you don't belong here you don't
belong at a high school party Miss oh
well yeah we're leaving let me just stay
back okay just let go of stay back get
out of here come on touch
me oh oh
oh
go